[Music]
the University of lake house no not damn
dude this movie's romantic man it's a
romantic ass movie we ain't sitting
there and he leaves a little uh a letter
in the mailbox and he's writing to this
woman I love you so they live in
different time zones like they live in
the same house but different times
interesting yeah and they become pen
pals well if they end up being
interdimensional [__] friends is what
they've ended up
kissy friends PG friends
have been a sex scene in a PG film
um I've heard [__] in a PG film what
you're allowed one really yeah
wow I didn't know that I believe yeah
that'd be interesting though can you
imagine like it would have to be I mean
like it wouldn't be anything but I'm
just curious if the insinuation of sex
has been in a PG film
the steamiest scenes in Pete of course
[__] nice animated nice
uh okay Jessica Rabbit Road to El Dorado
Enchanted and placates Giselle and some
hanky and some hanky-panky I [__]
hate that phrase dude for sex Hanky
Panky [__] off with that
Courtney admires a near naked Mitch nice
dude
I'm not connecting with any of these
the live action Scooby-Doo gets rather
dirty
Dragon can't keep what what I what I
would not give to ca foxing with donkey
and dragon
yeah we'll just make one no if I wanted
like the actual team to do it
could you imagine that little donkey on
that big dragon yeah because they have
kids yeah it happens strong nut
powerful powerful nut you got a nut hard
to get it all the way up how little that
[__] isn't compared to that dragon look
at the amount yeah like dragon come must
be huge yeah a lot yeah so he has some
potent semen do you think she does he
think like after he nutted in her she
had to like stand like upside down yeah
she like laid her back and put her knees
up yeah yeah yeah yeah she's like what's
your favorite uh Eddie Murphy has donkey
or the dragon and Mulan oh I would say
it is the literal same performance it is
but I'm still gonna go donkey
that's fair he's more iconic I love
Mulan though yeah yeah it's a good one
Mulan didn't have that strong of a
impression on me as a child
so my friend asked a really interesting
question though because you know Mulan
it's revealed that she's a woman at the
end whatever and she hooks up with uh
yeah the guy oh boy and my friend
brought up a good question and he said
do you think he just went straight for
her ass
because of like the relationship they've
had so far
so I just thought I'd pose it to you too
so you're asking me like I'm talking
first time oh you know put on some
[__] AC DC get the mood right
and does he he doesn't even look at
anything besides that ass he's claiming
it because because that's all he's known
right so it's like it's it's like a
weird thing where he's like oh
you know she's a girl whatever but it
seemed like he was [__] ready to get
in I don't remember their relationship
leading up so that's what I'm struggling
with oh extremely extremely when she
when she was him was he into him I think
so from what I remember
I'm a woman he's like
I think he's just like it'll do yeah
that's what I mean like he's just like
yeah that's what I'm saying do you think
well so you do think that he would just
go straight for the ass then
I mean okay assuming I'm talking thick
loogie spitting
and just getting in there
assuming that's the question assuming
that leading up
he's thinking that she's been a man up
until this point and he's like
developing
feelings see he's trying to kiss her but
she's like I don't think I want this and
he's like you kiss me right now right
remember that part in the movie The
forceful kissing I don't yeah there was
oh yeah yeah the floors will go yeah
that one
um
not I think assuming if he was like in
love with with bro
then yeah I think he's gonna go like
right for the right for the cheeks
that's what I was thinking that's just
whenever I heard the question for the
first time it was just very perplexing
so I thought I made me think for a bit
that's a crazy ass thought to have after
watching Mulan like he'd finish his
Mulan and he goes you think he went
straight for the ass
because if you watch if you were fresh
out of Mulan I think the answer would be
much quicker I think you're just like
yeah yeah
after you're giving it some time you
haven't seen it for a bit
yeah I think I'm trying to think I
haven't seen Mulan since
uh controversial opinion best soundtrack
of a Disney movie all Disney films I
think so am I oh in my opinion oh man
let's play that
[Music]
this is why I couldn't do Disney movies
as a kid that song's good it this is
grating to me really yeah
I thought that was a thoroughly
enjoyable song when I was younger I
still find it enjoyable I just feel like
my red Terminator eyes turning on and
just being what you what did you watch
as a kid then
um I wasn't allowed to watch much God
here we go
um
I wasn't okay
so I just think that made movies like
this very like this is annoying yeah
but I like I think so you never watched
a film as a child no like I'm trying to
think Independence Day that was like a
great movie I love it as a kid come on
now You Really Gonna Hate on
Independence Day even better
what's his name from Independence Day I
I just learned this recently he went
[__] ape [__] after doing that
character
um Will Smith no no
oh he yeah he punched the [__] out of
Christopher go look at the cast I lost
so much respect for Will Smith after
that
hidden hidden Chris yeah I was like what
a [__] dumb ass dude come on
because a bald joke come on man uh
you're winning already Randy Quaid
I think Randy Quaid was already kind of
a bit batshit crazy if I'm being honest
no for sure but all he was doing was
[__] National Lampoon Vacation movies
and all of a sudden it's like God Randy
you're so crazy now after Independence
Day no but like I I maybe I don't know
the exact timeline but if I'm correct I
feel like the timeline is he did
Independence Day and then he became very
like openly like vocal about like I
don't know anti-government type [__] and
then most recently like
I don't know the last 10 years I got
like arrested because him and his wife
like [__] tried to Rob some people
and nice man yeah good for Randy yeah
dude
they just became you ain't never did
dude never did a Chantix commercial
that's true dude
Randy will do everything but a [__]
Chantix dude
became the president's official spokes
unofficial spokesman
oh wow
didn't know that
yeah
Independence Day there it is yeah dude
he's just still doing the character to
Trump which uh [__] aliens
where they're coming they're like are
you serious Randy
are you serious they got big [__]
heads there are you a big are you a big
alien guy no like Tom Delong no
are you no I don't give a [__] honestly
yeah people I don't know like people
like they're out there I'm like probably
yeah what the [__] I mean
I have a I have a growing growing like
tumor of uh apathy like towards things
I just can't